and then the blood has just thrown away
and here we've made it into uh perhaps
most valuable resource on Earth so hello
I'm back Blood Sweat and Tears have been
shed these past months of absence but
enough sweating was done during the
summer tears have already been shed so
that just leaves me with blood and
whether taking a part of blood and
injecting it into Old animals is enough
for rejuvenation
that's right many of you may remember
earlier this year I made a video on the
oldest living rats and now we have some
updates in particular what actually were
these rats given and what changes were
seen showing both some dilation results
and some glycan age data sound
interesting great let's go so firstly we
should probably recap on what I
mentioned last time the The Story begins
with Dr Harold catcher who on coming
across some early work on heterochronic
parabiosis began his own search for a
human Rejuvenation therapy heterochronic
parabiosis involves surgically joining
two animals together such that they
share a circulatory
system previous data has shown that when
you do heterochronic parabiosis between
old and young animals the old animals
seem to benefit in particular there this
land paper in 2005 by the comboy lab
that showed that it ulated aging
phenotypes so catchup sort out further
test this Theory and he was a supporter
of the presence of there being
potentially rejuvenating factors in
young blood so long story short he sets
up a study to inject old rats with
concentrated blood plasma this
concentrated blood plasma was called
E5 rats beginning at 2 years old were
then injected four times with this E5
over 8 days and then received the second
dose later on at day 95 following these
injections many measurements were made
many of which are described in Catcher's
book The Illusion of knowledge and in my
previous video I tried to un allude to
these claims and we saw some videos
showing that these treated old rats seem
to have better grip strength and some
other preliminary data suggesting that
this E5 injection was reducing the DNA
mation age approx that's used for
biological age with one of the female
rats SE at the time of me making that
previous video being the longest lived
sprog dly rat now there's a new preprint
with some updates to the study so
firstly we'll take a look at some of
these updates in terms of measurements
and then we'll discuss the interesting
question which I left untouched last
time which is what is
E5 so I don't think this data changed
but I'm going to show it again anyway
and that is this D name inflation
data where essentially they're looking
at the epigenetic marks in different
tissues of these rats and whether or not
the old treated rats had a similar
pattern to older rats or to younger
rats and although this graph is labeled
very badly in my opinion because I'm
assuming the blue bar here is
representing the young Rats the red bar
being the old rats and the orange bar
being the old rats that were given E5
you can see that there's close a match
between the blue and the orange bars
suggesting that the epigenetic age this
D name inflation test is more similar
between the older treated rats and the
younger rats suggesting as they claim in
this paper that E5 was having a
Rejuvenation effect on the different
tissues tested here the liver blood
heart and
hypothalamus with the change being the
lowest in the hypothalamus which could
be linked to what is this E5 but we'll
come back to that in a second because
the data that was sort of updated here
is that now we have some information on
glycan age so this is looking at Sugar
modifications to the IGG Protein that's
found in blood as can be seen in this
figure notably there was a significant
reduction in the relative abundance of
the pro-inflammatory a galact oated
igg2a glycoform
g while there was a increase in the
anti-inflammatory dgala oated glycoform
G2 and this is following three doses of
E5 treatments now I have to put my hand
up and say I don't know much yet about
the functions of these glycon
modifications but they do seem to be
going in the opposite direction to what
seems to be happening with age so
potentially that could also elucidate
what's going on here anyway what these
preliminary data suggest is that there
is some sort of effect happening with E5
in terms of the older treated rats
having similar biomarkers to the younger
rats which raises the question as what
exactly is E5 and how could it
potentially be having these effects in
the first place so it will comes back to
blood and blood can be separated into
three main layers a layer containing the
red blood cells will uh potentially be
visiting them soon in a video The Buffy
coat which contains the white blood cell
and platelets and the big remaining
fraction is plasma now this is a big
fraction it's mostly water some proteins
ions hormones and nucleic acids and this
is what catcher was most interested in
which is a good thing because 50% of the
blood is plasma but what part of the
plasma well the plasma fraction that
they termed E5 is the fraction derived
from the platelet-free plasma of young
pigs 6 to 7 7 months old an age at which
is according to this article reflective
of the mamalian youthful homeostatic
Peak and this paper now actually
explains how exactly they extracted this
E5 fraction so following blood
extraction from the pigs they kept the
plasma and then they treated it with
polyethylene glycol Peg which is a
polymer that can be used to precipitate
extracellular
festical these are small membrane bound
particles that can car various molecules
and signals between cells but are
present at low concentrations in plasma
so by following this procedure doing
some spinning steps and then separating
fractions by size they could concentrate
this large volume of plasma into a small
volume containing a high concentration
of these extracellular vesicles and it's
this fraction this E5 fraction that they
injected into the rats so this isn't
plasma exchange NE is it the rats just
being given blood but it's specifically
this extracellular fical fraction of the
plasma that it's being given to the rats
which they describe as being E5 so does
e stand for extract or EV either way
what are
EVS well EVS extracellular vesicles is a
general term for all secreted vesicles
that are released from cells into the
extracellular
environments they can contain both
proteins and orang
and and both these proteins and RNA can
carry information and that information
could be used as a way that cells
communicates at least in this interview
catcher seems to think that the
components responsible for these
potential rejuvenating effects are
coming from micro
rnas I suspect it's it's a micro
RNA a subset of rnas that are created
within the
cell fun news I made a video on micro
rnas about 3 years ago but it seems like
they're still investigating what exactly
about these exosomes or these
extracellular fical is actually
attributing is actually causal to these
effects that they're
noticing at this stage nobody knows uh I
suspect it's it's a micro
rnas which are
uh sign ific in controlling
translation I suspect it's also RNA
binding
proteins which are which are very much
Disturbed in in the aging
process and RNA processing
proteins and I myself am for sure
interested so there has been some
updates I now have a better
understanding of what this study was
about but I feel like there's still some
gaps in terms of how exactly it's
happening and in terms of the robust
lifespan analysis of the
rats but this is still a preprint and so
hopefully soon we will actually get the
peer refused paper and when that does
come out I will hopefully make a video
on it so with that I hope you've enjoyed
my return if you're bloodthirsty for
more content then check out this video
here thank you to my Patron supporters
and thank you for
listening